es mi ex novia ex novia
[Risas]
[Música]
voy a fijarme si son más altos que ella
cree que es una prioridad defender
cabello largo no lo sé no debe ser
atractivo si por favor
ella siempre les hará muchas preguntas
creo que lo manejaremos muy bien así
será
[Música]
y empieza
y
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y
[Risas]
[Música]
hola cómo están bien y tú
davis
gabri lo siento lo recordaré
mucho como este soy gay soy son y son y
si es un placer primera impresión que
era muy hermosa es
hermosa
y tú eres genial
gracias por señalar a la derecha
pensé que eras muy linda
eres hermosa
pero mi mamá no
nos aporta mi cabello
que estudie me mudé a san diego estudiar
vivo ahí desde hace 4 años estudió
comunicación social con una
especialización en sociología y cambio
social bien también me especialicé en su
solo jia
si estoy haciendo una maestría para ser
consejero familiar
o terapia de parejas y familias que
estás buscando
una relación alguien que pueda ser como
mi mejor amiga para divertirnos conocer
a alguien genial y que ella decida
alguien que me dé paz ha estado en
algunas relaciones que gatica así es
dejar todo fluir no quiero pensar en el
futuro todavía he estado soltero por dos
años en serio si estoy concentrado en
estudiar a qué te dedicas estoy
estudiando y trabajo en protección
ejecutiva estudio producción musical
solo estoy estudiando estudió medicina
entonces quiere ser doctor exacto y
radiólogo radiólogo vaya me gustaría
trabajar en todo el mundo disfruto mucho
tener experiencias nuevas y conocer
personas alertas sería una de las
ciertas uff si toxicidad a no
comunicarse pero creo que no tenemos
esencia doble medio del compromiso sí
esa es mi alerta que salga mucho pero no
lo sé no soy muy inseguro ser infiel
creo que es lo único que el resto puede
resolverse
[Risas]
denis gabri un placer
gracias
en alerta y blues
ah
señala a los tres
son y
muy bien
tú
[Música]
y tú
genial
[Música]
cómo estás muy bien gracias de nuevo
como ustedes gracias cómo estás qué
bueno verte digo lo mismo qué es lo más
importante en una relación para ti creo
que la confianza confianza y
comunicación no sentía confianza en mí
última relación no por mí sino por ella
yo soy muy honesto no me gusta engañar a
nadie así debe ser exacto comunicarse es
muy importante me gustan las personas
honestas y que sepan expresarse en los
momentos malos y buenos así podemos
resolverlo juntos como como debería ser
tienes alguna pregunta para mí o sobre
la relación si la pregunta más obvia por
qué crees que terminaron crees que
podría haber funcionado
no
solo quería saber si todavía se siente
es que tienen algo si sólo son amigos y
no por eso accedieron a esto no tengo
otra pregunta en realidad terminamos por
mí fue por mi answer entiendo esta fue
mi primera relación no sabía muy bien lo
que querían también me afectó no saber
manejar el tiempo
creo que estudias mucho no si bien
cuando terminaron fue hace poco si la
primera vez fue hace un año y la última
vez fue hace dos meses quedaron en
buenos términos y me alegra a ninguno es
tóxico no de perfecto es difícil a veces
aceptamos más de lo que podemos manejar
me alegra de que haya sido consciente en
sí sí
gracias
muy bien fue un placer denis sony sony
cielos
sabes a quién vas a elegir
si de ellos 3 sí eso creo
a quien hubiese elegido de todos los
chicos con los que denis y tú se
sentaron a hablar son y si buena energía
sentí su confianza siento que le gusta
dirigir una conversación estoy tan
acostumbrada a hacer lo que me gusta
cuando alguien quiere dirigirla así
puedo descansar sí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
hola hola
es un placer conocerte igualmente
entonces ya no está mi novia
gracias denis
sorprendida yo también
félix si se lo agradezco me das tu
instagram sí genial grabación en su
teléfono irás a san diego luego sí habrá
tráfico sí por la hora y del día del
trabajo
bueno bueno
vivo ya tienes millones si te escribiré
su efecto suena bien sí
jubilee vive intensamente